[Laughter]
Blake Lively playfully trolls a fan I
just like to to have fun it all went
down at a wrexham game over the weekend
in Wales Blake and her hubby Ryan
Reynolds co-owned the Welsh football
team along with their pal Rob mcelhaney
how did you explain this to your wife
I'm not that dumb Kevin I I promise you
I would consult my wife before putting
pants on she's as obsessed as I am she's
already like looking at the schedule
throughout the year wondering which
matches she can attend Ryan wasn't lying
Blake was ever the passionate fan at a
game over the weekend the actress
greeted people around the arena and even
took a special request that ended in a
big laugh you say hi to Stephanie it's
my girlfriend
yeah you heard that right Blake's got
jokes
[Laughter]
but don't worry the couple is still
together the fan shared on Twitter his
girlfriend cried happiness and is
absolutely over the moon adding luckily
she hasn't broken up with me she really
does just show me how to be better in
almost every way but Bleak fans know the
girl's a big prankster especially when
it comes to her man I love the troll
with you and your hubby it's my favorite
kind of follow back we have fun we're
best friends so you know earlier this
year the Gossip Girl star shared this
video of a nervous Ryan on the Jumbotron
as he watched a match she wrote I bought
ESPN plus today just to watch my husband
experience crippling anxiety live worth
it I understand the absolutely gorgeous
disaster uh slow motion train wreck that
is the sport of football I'm obsessed
now seems that playfulness is the secret
behind the couple's 10-year marriage you
know it's it's impossible not to get
along with him Ryan and Blake welcome to
Baby number four earlier this year for
under 10 years old how excited are you
and Blake we're very excited you know uh
we'd have to be you know you'd have to
be a to do this four times if you
didn't like it yeah the two have lots to
celebrate on and off the football field
I'm you know I'm I'm paired up with my
best friend and that's I know rob you
and Caitlin are the same way it's it's
you know when that happens you you
recognize how unbelievably lucky you are
cheers to winning matches and winning
over fans hearts
believe him
[Music]
foreign